what's going on guys this is Rob and an
anticipation of the spider-verse film we
are covering the end of the spider-verse
yes the death of the spider-verse in
Marvel Comics and this story has a
ridiculously amazing ending and I'm
really curious to see how you guys feel
about this so what this does is this
initially opens up with Peter Parker
speaking with Norman Osborne pray tell
why Peter Parker is speaking with Norman
Osborne you may be saying as you're
watching this video because Peter's
working for Norman Osborne crazy right
Norman Osborne's the Green Goblin he's
literally Peter's greatest enemy and
this is cool because they're basically
allies now all this took place during
zebwell's Spider-Man run as always if
you want to get caught up make sure you
guys check the link in the description
but the long and short of this is that
Norman Osborne basically being the
finance year for Peter Parker allows him
to be a more effective Spider-Man and in
fact one of the things that Norman
Osborne has been doing is he's been
providing money to Peter that allows him
to either use Norman's technology or use
his own Ingenuity to develop a more
enhanced spider suit to give him
different Technologies like a little
Spider-Man robot and so on and so forth
it's a cool development with his
character but the reason why Norman
Osborne is hitting up Peter is because
an Oscorp truck has been hijacked now I
promise you a hijacked truck is not the
main Crux of the end of the spider-verse
the truck crashes into the web of life
and Destiny and all the Spider-Man Die
thanks for watching guys peace I promise
you that's not what happens
do not worry but of course Peter does
the normal Spider-Man stuff which is
swinging in and you know basically
getting the guy out of the truck and
then handing him over to the authorities
and yada yada yada all the normal
Spider-Man stuff what's cool about this
is this entire situation is being
watched by a woman called shathra who's
the current controller or the person who
manages What's called the Great Nest
which is what used to be the web of life
and Destiny now a little bit of
explanation here for people who don't
know what this is the web of life and
Destiny is one of the most important
elements in the history of the
Spider-Man Mythos and the easiest way to
explain it is to give you a scenario so
let's imagine that it's like Monday and
Peter Parker has to go to the post
office on the way to the post office he
gets into a fight with Venom and some
innocent bystanders killed and the
innocent bystander was working on a cure
for cancer they're dead The Cure never
gets put out there in the world now a
person who is in control of the web of
life and Destiny specifically the master
Weaver as they're called would see this
entire event unfold before it happens so
what they would do is they would
actually pull on the string of Peter
Parker and instead of Peter going to the
post office he would go to like Walmart
so the fight never takes place the
bystander Never Dies and the cure for
cancer is never prevented that's how the
web of life and Destiny works now
everybody has a kind of role they play
Within the web of life and Destiny Peter
Parker's What's called the chosen one at
least he is at the time this story
starts you also have like the Scion and
you've got Cindy Moon and different
things like that and we'll talk about
those characters as time goes on but the
web of life and Destiny is important
because it is quite literally a web that
intertwines all the different spiders
together and so what chathra has been
doing is basically taking over the web
of life and Destiny controlling it and
basically corrupting or killing every
single Spider-Man and Spider-Woman from
across the Multiverse now this plot may
sound familiar it may sound just like
the original spider-verse event it is
not and one of the reasons why it is not
is because as this whole thing
transpires a portal is opened up from
the realm of shatra and like all these
crazy little like spider was awesome
things come flying out there all they
normally do is just attack a spider and
basically kill them and that's
effectively it but as a kind of Aid that
comes to Peter Parker by way of other
Spider-Man and spider-women from across
the Multiverse who are watching this
he's met by the arrival of more Lund now
here's the thing Morlan I would argue
while people say that Norman Osborne is
the most significant enemy of Peter
Parker more Lon is the most powerful
like one of the things that's
established here in this story and
really ever since Moreland was first
introduced to Marvel Comics he's every
bit as strong as the Incredible Hulk and
like Peter Parker's commented on that
the first time they fought Peter said
like this guy punched harder than the
Hulk it's crazy how strong Moreland is
now Morlan is what you call an inheritor
in years past in Marvel Comics morelon
and the inheritors would travel around
the Multiverse and consume the life
force of every Spider-Man and
Spider-Woman they could possibly find
now the reason why Moore Lund does this
is because as inheritors they feed on
what are called totems basically avatars
of animals on Earth so Peter Parker
represents spiders there was a point
where moulan went to wakanda and like
tried to start some problems with black
panther and black panther was like sun
sun sun you don't want this smoke he
whooped his ass I mean just beat the
hell out of Moreland and they ran him
out
more London got wrecked it was
absolutely amazing but it was it was a
really really cool moment there more
London and the inheritors they prefer
spider totems in the same way that you
and I prefer Chinese food it just tastes
better you know what I mean like it's
just that kind of a thing so when
Maulana arrives here on the scene
naturally and rightfully so Peter Parker
immediately attacks him because every
single time more Lunds ever appeared in
Marvel Comics it's been to kill Peter
Parker he's always been there to just
kill the guy right and then like absorb
his life Essence and in a lot of ways
the reason why is because Peter Parker
at least those of us who have been down
the romantic road the romance Road once
or twice the one they got away you know
what I mean like you got to try to get
them back and that's literally what it
is now of course more Lon is actually
trying to talk to Peter and there's a
point when he just stops fighting him
but Peter Parker realizing how dangerous
Moreland is keeps attacking him anyway
now in the midst of all this when more
lunge is kind of overpowers Peter what
ends up happening is Cindy Moon and
Miles Morales come come to his Aid now
Miles Morales I think is a character
that a lot of you are probably familiar
with if for no other reason than the
into the spider-verse films he's
basically a character or person who
became the new Spider-Man after the
death of Peter Parker in the Ultimate
Universe a whole different branding
initiative from Marvel Comics Cindy moon
is much less known and in reality I hope
we get to see her in film form because
she's amazing but Cindy moon is also a
girl who has Spider-Man Powers the
difference is that when she first showed
up it was hilarious her and Peter were
like romantically drawn and it was more
than just like damn she's hot and her
being like damn he's hot right like
let's go bang no it was like their
connection through like the web of life
and Destiny that they were drawn
together and so literally these two
couldn't stop banging I mean like you
couldn't you couldn't pry them apart
with a crowbar like it was just every
time you turned a page it's like yep
there's Peter Parker and Cindy moon man
just touching naughty bits you know what
I mean like it just they couldn't stop
it was hilarious one of the funniest
moments in the Spider-Man Mythos but of
course Cindy Moon and Miles Morales were
also a part of the original spider-verse
event so they know who Morlan is and
they understand the threat of Mormon
being here here's the irony behind all
of this even Jessica Drew shows up
Spider-Woman she appears Spider-Man Noir
comes through a portal and he shows up
now the reason why they're all even here
in the first place is because they were
kind of pulled together that's the way
the web of life and Destiny works is
that all the Spider-Man and Spider-Woman
are kind of intertwined right they're
all sort of connected in a different way
this kind of connection has manifested
in different capacities for example
during the original spider-verse event
Spider-Man 2099 Miguel O'Hara there was
a point when he could actually feel the
deaths of every version of himself
around the Multiverse now some of this
was due to a contraption that he had
that basically tapped into his brain
waves and allowed him to experience the
lives of himself across the Multiverse
but it was also the web of wife and
Destiny the problem with this is that
these different spider wasps that exist
out there are more for just killing
spiders that they're actually there to
corrupt them to infect them and so when
Spider-Man Noir shows up they all just
kind of celebrate the moment because
he's basically there to help them out
but then he immediately grabs Jessica
Drew and then as soon as he does he
stabs her through the stomach with an
inheritor dagger and people are like
what are you doing man like you're
supposed to be on our side why are you
attacking Jessica Drew and what he says
is that with this dagger she's been
severed from the web of life and Destiny
now because the web of life and Destiny
also serves as the basis behind the life
force for the different Spider-Man and
spider-women who are out there that in
effect once she stabbed and she severed
from it she basically starts to
literally unravel she turns into like a
giant thing of webbing and just falls to
the ground she dies now the way in which
she dies is one of the most overdramatic
things ever she's like screaming and
she's worried about her child and like
who's gonna take care of her kid right
as if such a thing is relevant of course
it is guys I'm just messing with you but
it is one of the one of these cool
things because because what ends up
happening is more Lund then turns around
and attacks Spider-Man Noir and that's
when he tells Peter I'm sent here to
help you I'm not here to be your enemy
now having more Lun on their side is
huge it is immense because this guy
again won he's exceedingly well versed
in virtually any and all capabilities of
Spider-Man because this guy spent eons
along with the other inheritors they
spent eons traveling around the
Multiverse and killing Spider-Man so you
would be hard-pressed to find a
Spider-Man out there in the universe
we're in the Multiverse even that could
defeat more Lund the only exception to
that was the Peter Parker and I forgot
what Earth he was from somebody in the
comments remind me because I can't
remember what Earth he was from exactly
but it was the Peter Parker who never
lost the Enigma Force right like
basically the Peter Parker who could
operate on a cosmic level he was like
this cosmically Godly powerful like like
Spider-Man and then gets his life
Essence absorbed in the most ridiculous
way ever people were pissed when he he
died but he was amazing right but it's
that kind of thing right outside of a
character like that you'd be
hard-pressed to find a Spider-Man that
could go Toe to Toe with more luns
successfully and survive for any measure
of time so he's a massive Ally to have
here more so than that what he says is
the reason why he's here is because
there is a threat that's greater than
the inheritors because it's not enough
to Simply have these different
Spider-Man being killed off the reason
why they're dying is because they refuse
to turn to the side of shatra right so
it's either be corrupted and basically
turn to her side or be killed now one of
the things and one of the distinctions
that I want to put here is that not
everybody who turns does so willingly
some do right some like turn to her
cause willingly and choose to join her
side but others are forced into doing it
but regardless of the situation
Spider-Man Noir is one of the Spider-Man
who have been corrupted and with his Aid
it's leading to the deaths of all these
different Spider-Man more so than that
like when he tells them you guys have no
friends out there in the Multiverse what
he says is I actually lied you do have
friends out there on the Multiverse the
problem is that all your friends are now
enemies so like spider Punk and
spider-gwen and all these different
versions of Spider-Man are corrupted by
the power of shatra and literally
traveling around and either killing or
corrupting other Spider-Man but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end I'm excited to get to the
rest of this because the story gets
amazing thank you all for watching let
me know if you want me to cover the rest
in the comments section and I will catch
you all later
peace